I got so I felt I was going to die I'm
not exaggerated I felt I was going to
die the peace how are you guys doing it
ready for another exciting episode my
special guests how are you dr. Joe cigar
so how you been good any good how have
you been I've been great thank God thank
God are you looking good thank you thank
you thank you so I'm trying to I'm
trying it's very important I want to
start off with a story of a doctor so I
want a doctor Brogan I don't know if
you've heard of dr. Brogan no dr. Brogan
why don't we do this I want to we're
going to kind of get your feedback on
what the doctor has to say he's going to
go into our topic whether we're going to
be discussing so I'll watch it and we're
going we'll have a breakdown of it how's
that sure but it's my belief that in
this health climate if you don't access
your inner compass and if you do exactly
what your doctor tells you to do there
are very good odds that you're going to
spend a lot of your life sick and that's
why we have to look behind the curtain
we have to look at the fact that Western
medicine is killing us and we have to
start considering that despite the fact
that our doctors are probably very
well-intentioned people who put blood
sweat and tears into their training we
have to start asking who is funding that
training because some of us are speaking
out about the fact that our training and
medical education are bought
unfortunately in the balance between
benefits and risks it is an
uncomfortable truth that most drugs do
not work in most patients so before I
read this condemning quote in the
British Medical Journal I had already
taken a very deep dive into ghostwritten
suppressed and manipulated data that
essentially undermined all of gold
standard practice in psychiatry and
obstetrics my specialties and even the
Mayo Clinic begrudgingly agrees that 40%
of practice should be discarded
but unfortunately according to data it
takes 17 years for this science to
trickle trickle into your doctors hands
so this is how modern medicine is not
reflecting modern science and by modern
science I mean concepts like the
microbiome like epigenetics like toxic
and exposure and like biochemical
individuality we are still using a model
that employs a one gene one ill one pill
system of understanding and the problem
is that this model is totally
ill-equipped to tell you as an
individual how you will react with
regard to efficacy and safety to a given
pharmaceutical intervention okay that
this was a health educator Jim Marlow
had told me about this dr. Brogan
she's also a student of I don't know if
you've heard of the the dr. genius dr.
Nicholas Gonzalez sure yeah she studied
with him for some time she's one of the
a psychiatrist psychologist psychiatrist
is the one I can prescribe drugs right
and dear a deal yeah and her story is
that she used to prescribe a lot of
drugs a lot of drugs and after some time
you know she really like dwelled into
the science behind it and she saw there
was no science and then she started to
really get into nutrition and she
started as she does now she started to
make that a model in her practice now
get this this is a psychiatrist a
medical doctor who's getting people off
drugs telling us that most of these
drugs psychotic drugs make people
psychotic she's they they they're not
effective the 30 percent they are it's
more of a placebo effect and they're
causing far more harm than good what is
a layman like myself and many of
many of the people out there she's
helping people get off depression get
off these drugs and she's getting people
into meditation into nutrition amongst
other things but the main thing is that
she's trying to get them off drugs and
and have a lifestyle shift a lifestyle
change and she's warning people about
you know watching this one this this
whole thing of there's a pill for every
ill you heard it what do you have to say
what do you thoughts on that well I mean
I'm I totally agree wholeheartedly of
everything that she's talking about and
you know my practice I very really
prescribed medications and I think that
it all starts in medical school
obviously you know we're all being
taught pharmaceutical treatments and
surgical seat and treatment so it's all
symptomatic medicine and you know when
you approach a patient from a
symptomatic standpoint and and you only
have five or ten minutes of an office
visit spending with them
you're almost you know forced to to
prescribe them something because that's
you know what they're looking for and
and you know one of the reasons
osteopathic medicine came about was
really to help wake up the medical
profession in that you know we need to
treat our patients from a place of
health and that we need to find a cause
of what's happening with the patient in
order to do that number one it takes
time you got to listen to the patient
you have to treat the patient person
last time we we spoke here we did talk a
little bit about that and so you can't
do that in a five or ten minute office
visit and and so if a physician like
myself goes to medical school and our
medical school is just like the
allopathic or MD schools we're taught
the same medical stuff if that's all
we're taught and we go into our
residency program and that's all we're
taught then that's all we're going to do
most of these physicians that come out
of medical school and residences 99.9%
of them are relying on research articles
and publications to tell them what the
standard of care is and unfortunately
predominantly those research articles
stimulated by the drug companies it's
about you know a certain medication drug
how's that going to have an effect on a
certain condition in my case and and in
the what I call traditional osteopathic
medicine we're taught not only medicine
and there is a time and a place for
medicine if you know how to use it
appropriately but we're also taught how
to understand health and how to use our
hands to treat our patients but it's not
manipulation it's not some new-age form
of medicine you have to develop certain
perceptual skills tactile senses with
your hands but also perceptual skills
with your mind and and it's similar to
meditating and and sensing certain
things that is happening in the body and
for example since we're talking so much
about drugs if a person is taking
steroids or narcotics or antibiotics or
blood pressure medications or or you
know other types of pain medications
chemotherapy for example for the cancers
it has an effect on the body
physiologically we know that I mean you
look at the drug modules and you see all
the side effects you can read a bottom
this listen lists of them but if you
develop perceptual skills and you place
your hands on the patient you can
actually feel what those drugs are doing
to people you can feel it on a physical
physiological sense but you could also
feel what's happening to their psyche
how is a certain there there are
different parts to the human being most
people are looking at the structure the
skin the bones the muscles the ligaments
the organs that's what we can see with
our eyes there are other functions that
operate in your body and actually move
through your body there are functions
that are fluid in nature that are
actually invisible it's not the life
force that we're talking about other the
Chi in Chinese medicine is our there are
electromagnetic forces that actually are
in the body but also move through the
skin and if you get too
patience one taking drugs the other one
who does excuse me doesn't take the
drugs and you put your hands on these
people and this is what we do and we
have students coming in the office we
train them to feel the difference
between the two and what the drug is
actually doing to that person so it will
have an effect on the on the bio
electrical system certain drugs certain
drugs will have an effect on the tissue
or the physical system and certain drugs
will have an effect on the fluid part of
the system and and so it's a it's kind
of a difficult thing for me to describe
in words it's much easy for me to you
know demonstrate this with a some things
are more demonstrations you can
understand sure sure sure and and you
know when I'm taking a patient off of
medications because very often I'm
beginning patients in my office who are
on drugs and many of them and they want
to come off on and they go see their
other physicians and they say you know
you have to be on these drugs for the
rest of your life and they don't accept
that they come to me I said no you don't
have to be on these drugs for the rest
of your life and here's how we're going
to do it I have to look at these
different systems the fluids the tissue
the potency we call it or the bio
electrical field which helps me
determine the level of health of the
individual and when it's the right time
to wean the patient off of the
medication how much I can wean them off
how long it's going to take me and you
know how the patient's going to tolerate
that and because I went to medical
school I have the responsibility to deal
with these drugs I understand what they
are I'm not going to send someone to a
non-medical individual to take someone
off medicine they can't do it and I'm
the licensure yeah I have the licensure
for that and and I'm comfortable dealing
with all kinds of drugs what's the
success rate if you from a hundred
people you know thousand over the years
60 70 80 percent for these people to
have come in and they want to get out of
drugs what's the success rate usually
well how many of them are you able in a
do simple situation someone's on one
drug hundred percent no problem you got
a patient who's really
check let's say they're in kidney
failure or or they have chronic liver
disease or you know that blood pressure
is sky-high and you know they're not
wanting to manage it properly which
means there's only so much I can do if
they're not following good nutrition if
they're not addressing other issues that
can cause disease like you talk with
doctor Garcia and metals in the mouth
there's so many factors stress in their
life are they willing to make those
change they have to be responsible for
that I make every single patient in my
practice responsible for their own
health yeah but I work with them that's
the problem most people they want the
magic pill of course everything's you
know just going to be okay I take tit
and now they see there's a lot of work
that has to go on my head yeah it's the
only way it's going to work
yeah there's no there's no free lunches
exactly one of my professors used to say
you have to work for ya earn it try
coming again you're black go there's no
no magic so you ought to put in the
blood sweat it doc to Joseph Grasso
hannity show don't go anywhere
come to LA are you guys doing
are you guys ready I'm ready
we're going to start
there might be some muscle tension in
that area
hey Gemma you are giving up bad blood of
your body to Waterloo oh yeah
back here on the Dean show dr. Joseph
Grasso now you've been practicing for is
almost over 30 years about 27 27 years
you have a lot of experience what is it
I mean you go to ask this question to a
neurologist and an oncologist the family
member
diagnosed with cancer you want to know
what's causing this what is the root
cause they kind of look at you like
you're you know from another planet it's
like okay if we can address the root
cause my common sense is telling me and
other experts also holistic minded
doctors are also looking for the root
cause but on this other side I'm asking
and I look at you like you know you're
just kind of weird so why do you have
this dilemma here you have this paradigm
total shift here from one end to the
other that's my next question is like
what when we talk to someone like
yourself someone who's more open-minded
open to exploring and you're not just
stuck by one model you're not just lying
folded just to and chained up as many I
feel doctors are they just they don't
want to look at anything else what
they've been told to believe that's it
it's kind of like a you know they're
it's kind of like their own religion in
a sense true
why is this and what is it well when we
say holistic what is that what does that
mean well first of all any physicians
don't have the tools to find the cause
and what I mean by that is they rely a
hundred percent on science okay
scientific studies that what do they do
they are studying disease and it's made
disease is made to look like the enemy
and disease is not always the enemy
disease is actually a very alive
functional process and many times it's
there
to help the patient wake up and to help
them really we look at their lives and
and make some changes okay so going back
to they don't have the tools
in order to find the cause you have to
synchronize with something else in the
individual and you have to spend time
treating that individual one office
visit after the next this is why
osteopathic medicine in its most
traditional sense and I think you know
indigenous cultures of the world
practice like this as well because they
understand nature and so if you get a
virus for example there's no drug that
kills a virus they haven't figured that
out yet they have drugs that can stop
the replication of a virus they can slow
it down but they don't have anything
that can kill it and the things with
viruses they're so smart that they can
mutate and change but your body has
everything it needs to kill and heal
anything doctor and retail is still who
is the founder of osteopathic medicine
we gave it its name first of all he said
ask the OP knees as old as the heavens
it's been around since time began but he
also said that the body was God's
drugstore
he's a very spiritual man and what he
meant by that is is the object of the
physician is to find health anyone can
find disease the system is so oriented
on disease how are they going to find
the cause of they're trying to suppress
symptoms sometimes the symptoms have to
express themselves and let another
patient to move to move on and you have
to help the patient to acknowledge that
so one way that we're trained and and
I'm not saying it is exclusive to
osteopathic physicians anyone who has
any sense of intuition or instinct can
feel certain things but to put them all
together they need to be adequately
trained yeah okay and it takes a long
time but what we're given in terms of
the tools is to feel health and the
health it by definition is something
that is in you it's in me it's and every
living thing on this planet that cannot
die
it can never be affected by disease it
can never be abused it can never be used
it can never be manipulated it's always
there
and the first thing that we're trying to
do from a traditional Osteopathic
perspective when we place our hands on
the patient even before that first of
all we ask permission can we come in
there and work with you
second of all we wait it's like a
meditation it's like praying you sit
back you wait a little while and all of
a sudden something opens up it's a very
spontaneous thing and if you have the
proper training you can learn to do this
fairly quickly from one treatment to the
next you have to get a patient to that
space first before they can heal and
when you get to that space the health
rises it just shows up it's very
difficult for me to put that into words
it's not some mystical thing if anyone
does any sense of meditation and they
feel something just shift and open up
this is what I'm talking about we call
it a neutral it's the first opening or
doorway that has to happen in order for
you to be clear and for the patient to
be moved by something that cannot die
and that's totally linked with the
divine yeah okay and and so when we get
to that space and going back to the
tools that you need to find the cause
and what holism is when you get to that
space it creates this blueprint and on
that blueprint it says this is what we
need to do with this patient to this day
and I'm telling you most of the time it
has nothing to do what they're
complaining about it's usually something
else that's going on it could be
something simple it be something you
know really old who knows okay until you
get there you don't know and from one
treatment to the next it changes yes if
you don't get to that space you're never
going to be able to find the cause and
today we got all these chronic diseases
let's take chronic limes for example I
see a lot of patients in my practice for
chronic limes if you take a history of
these patients they've had a lot of
problems in their lives
and then all of a sudden they get limes
is easy to do the testing they got three
to five bands and all of a sudden you've
got lines that's why you have all these
symptoms most of us could be exposed to
limes we never get it because
our immune systems are in order okay
everyone else and they see something
like this they're going to hit them
pretty hard with antibiotics they're
going to and some patients get you know
psychiatric sequel and they're going to
be on antidepressants and and have
neurological problems it's a pretty
significant issue and people are having
problems with that and and some of these
things need to be treated however you
don't need to beat up the body and kill
it even more okay and so when I see
these patients coming in they're taking
all these antibiotics I work very hard
to get them off the antibiotics and find
a better way what's your opinion when
you mentioned antibiotics I know I know
someone who he figured out that okay
look I go to the doctor he only sees me
five minutes he gives me antibiotics
he's got a family member is a medical
doctor he says hey I could skip the line
I put the antibiotics in my body I feel
better I'll just make a phone call
I'll get the you know the signature and
I can avoid all this wait in line and I
get that antibiotics quicker route and I
just keep taking antibiotics bad idea
that doesn't hat I was very buffered a
bit for the back it was the basic person
he thinks okay I'm saving time
antibiotics I'm going to heal I'm good I
feel better
if you're very healthy you shouldn't get
sick you may have time so you're going
to get sick and if you do shouldn't last
one of the day too
if it lasts longer than that there's
something going on and most people they
might get the sinusitis or the
pharyngitis or their ear infections they
take the drug but it comes back usually
I thought it's like 14 day is or 7 to 14
day common depends on the condition 10
days for pharyngitis could be about your
average cold well it's a virus they're
not going to prescribe it but in the
olden days when I went to a medical
school they will prescribe antibiotics
for everything whether they thought it
was a virus or not yeah these days there
is a little bit more consciousness about
the fact of what antibiotics are doing
and so physicians are we'll wait why is
it a bad idea you said it's a bad idea
because you're killing them it's a
double-edged sword you might be killing
the bad bacteria but you're Billa
killing the good stuff too and you're
making the patient more susceptible to
get further infections and that's what
happens especially with kids I got kids
you know some of the you know otitis
media you know their eardrums popped and
mother sees pus and blood coming out of
the year and they all freaking out okay
well what do you think they do when they
put tubes in there they break the
eardrum and everything's you know
leaking out it's actually a good thing
it's a body's way of trying to protect
the individual you don't need to give
antibiotics for that in the context of
what I'm doing if you're another called
holistic physician who doesn't put the
hands on the patient and all they're
doing is giving them supplements it's
not as effective okay because still
that's not holism it of course it's not
antibiotics and the supplements the
herbs are much better than antibiotics
not going to hurt the patient garlic all
that stuff is great that falls in the
line of mantle treating symptoms and you
may need to do that and I do that as
well but the reason why the patient even
if they have a simple sore throat yeah I
won't treat them over the phone is I
want to know why they got sick you're
looking for the root cause I want the
car you want the roof my guy and I have
to put my hands on the patient to figure
that out but the tumors in the brain I'm
asking the neurologists what's the root
cause he's like just genetic what do you
say is genetic
well you the the doctor here talked
about epigenetics which means that your
genes can change and the example that I
give my patients because it's pretty
obvious fish became amphibians because
the environment caused stress on the
fish that wasn't as much water so they
had to learn to live on land well your
body your body can do the same thing and
I tell my patients you don't have to
rely or worry about your family's
genetics you have to think about making
them better so that your offspring
offspring gets stronger and stronger and
it carries itself on from what from one
generation to the next
what I'm seeing Eddy in the last twenty
seven years of my medical experience
even in the last twenty years because of
all the other toxicities that were being
exposed to is a weakening of the gene
pool I'm seeing more and more sick
people chronically sick people
more and more challenges of treating
those people we can find a way to get
unhealthy but again you know it's a
combination of a lot of different things
and holistic medicine is not giving
herbs instead of you know pharmaceutical
drugs holism is treating the whole
person so looking fine body and spirit
uh-huh okay from head to toe talk to
doctor guy see we get a look at the mop
I dare do it dental sound every major
way that sounds like you know what we
call the single Thomas cent yeah common
sense also that just if common sense but
over here you need time to do it they
don't do that over here well nobody no
one does it you know I feel bad for
physicians I'm given some physicians
credit okay because I trained in this
system a lot of these people have good
hearts okay but they're subject to a
system that forces them live in fear of
practicing the standard of care so
someone comes in with a sore throat they
got to give you an antibiotic okay if
they have high blood pressure they have
to give you a medicine now if a patient
comes into my office repeatedly with a
blood pressure of 200 over 100 I'm going
to put them on something I'll try
something alternative but if it's not
working this is why I went to medical
school I will prescribe something I will
do the least as possible and I talk to
the patient I look them in the eye and I
say this is what we're doing this is why
we're doing it and this is and we're
going to get you off of this and but
this is what you're going to have to do
to get off this medicine so I'm not fond
of medications but I'm not going to let
a patient walk out my office and have a
stroke and then it's even worse okay so
I've seen medicine saved people's lives
and it works best in an emergent
situation as far as healing it's
horrific you mentioned you mentioned
don't lose your point there it's
horrific you said dr. Brogan and this is
a she says her colleagues who are also
come you know conventional doctors they
can't give her a hard time because they
don't know most of them they don't know
the science before she became more
holistic and it's very rare to find a
holistic psychiatrist
I think very few and she's one of them
she says that we don't get told that
most of the studies are not independent
studies and she talks about how they'll
be like let's say 99 studies that will
fail and then the pharmaceutical company
they'll be one just like almost kinda
and they'll use that one so what kind of
science is that that's like bought bogus
to the young side what kind of sign of
you mining finding whatever proof they
can to justify you know a treatment
regimen and she said that's bought
because then it's been it's been bought
it's like immunizations Eddie it's a
very classic issue because what's herd
immunity herd immunity is if we immunize
a hundred people they're all going to be
immunized they're going to be resistant
to whatever we say the measles none of
those people are supposed to get the
measles if we immunize all of them well
we're lucky if we get nineteen to twenty
percent that are protected okay this
whole thing that happened in Disneyland
in California half of those people
weren't even immune I were immunized and
they still got the measles okay so the
only way you get hurt immunity is if you
actually get the measles and you'll
never get it again they did they was
doing some I was watching somewhere they
were showing like The Brady Bunch and
remember the Brady Bunch show of course
there was going on they were showing
episodes where it really wasn't a big
deal how are you serious the measles
well he certainly got all the symptoms a
slight temperature a lot of dots and a
great big smile a great big smile no
school for a few days did you call the
doctor well I've been trying to honey
but the lines been busy well say hello
to my dotted son for me tell him I'll
bring him some comic books and I'll see
you later dear okay honey bye
[Music]
you've got measles golly mom is supposed
to know everything but do you have to
keep proving it you've got a temperature
- what do you mean - computer with
Mendel from school a little while ago
oh well it's his temperature 101 and
one-one
oh is that up I'm 100 in 1.2 and you get
right into this
dr. Porter's on the way over can I tell
Peter he 2 points behind me I'm sure
you'd appreciate your sympathy
now into bed Jan we've got the measles
all four of us boy this is the life in
this yeah if you have to get sick she
can't beat the measles that's right no
medicine inside or out like shots on me
don't even mention shut yeah hmm Jan had
chickenpox and Marsha and Cindy had
month there well we have a doctor we
choose at least we'll have all the
information on all the kids how long
have you had that red spot on your cheek
or breast bath dr. Porter the one on
your chin oh no tell me he's got the
measles of course we can't be sure and
Joyce had an examination
well we're practicing together now which
one of us do you want well I think in
order to prove a point to the boys he's
got the measles and they're not like
panicking and fear you know they're just
they call the doctor he's like no big
deal it's like they went through it and
then you you becomes through your immune
system it comes strengthens from you
wasn't it wasn't like in life well of
course it is I mean there are some their
conditions I'm not going to lie to you
there are there are childhood conditions
that can you know make kids really sick
you know mumps can cause orchitis you
know inflammation of the testicle and
can render a child you know infertile so
these are extremely this is it it seems
like they go where but the farm they
they capitalized offered of course they
do yes what they do and this is why I
practice the way I do because if I get a
child that comes into my
this hasn't been vaccinated and I have
quite a few the parents that's what they
choose to do and they have measles I put
my hands on a medi I treat them and
another holistic physician even if they
don't use their hands there are other
things you can treat a virus with like
you said garlic for example oil of
oregano there's a lot of different
things digestive enzymes you know for
pain and inflammation there are so many
different things that you can utilize
but like I said you know the reason I
went the route that I did was because I
wanted to be able to utilize everything
possible I didn't want to have any
limitations at all and the best way
you're going to get a firm diagnosis is
to put your hands on the patient and
sense health something in that patient
that cannot die it's totally linked to
something bigger that's the only way you
can do it like what you're saying before
that the person that originated with
this there was a connection with the
ultimate the reality the creator the
July there was some connection there and
this is something sometimes I mean this
goes above and beyond
you know empirical to I mean the just
observation what we see in field that's
one way science but some things that you
just have to be holistic like you're
saying you have to not just be limited
or and then over here being especially
limited to to junk science there's one
thing when it's real independent studies
and over here where it's funded by the
people the drug pushers my almost out of
time why why is there a drug store in
every corner I'm trying to figure this
once it connects I'm not even gonna
waste my breath now we have more people
on drugs but you Laurentian earlier when
we're talking just just more six people
coming in but then when dr. Weston price
you've heard of dr. was employee when he
went and visited many of these
indigenous communities and these people
this brilliant doctor he was a dentist
right and then he just started studying
their lifestyle how they were eating and
what you know they weren't exposed to
all the toxins and the food and holiday
a they little draw write it to them in
their environment and I tell
this is said before they had planes
trains and automobiles where's your
genetic makeup from your Northern
European descent think about what they
had available to them high protein high
fat diet myself a mostly Sicilian you
know Mediterranean type diet low fat
lots of fish actually I do very well on
that type of a diet so those there's a
lot of credence and I tell people the
proof is in the pudding we can tell you
whatever we want and I want the
listeners to understand that you know
I'm talking about putting your hands on
patients and and that there even if you
don't put your hands on the patient if
you have some sense of faith and trust
that that patients going to get well
that's just as powerful to help your
patients and as a psychologist a
psychiatrist she's giving her patients
the the power to take the collar back
and take a hold their health and and
find another way to do it a lot of
patients they don't it's like they're
not given the permission
they're told that they can't do it they
have to be on these things for the rest
of their lives and they're talking to a
very well educated physician so they
believe them that blocks the healing
that's why I've read a tremendous word
that the power of the mind where you
really truly believe this actually helps
with the heal sure sure and if you have
an open heart and you really have
compassion for people and you truly want
to help them the right way yeah not just
to suspend their symptoms okay
there's so much more you can do for
people you can truly help them heal but
we've got a couple few more minutes of
flu shots winters will be coming around
so everywhere in anywhere flu shots I
mean you go to Sam's Club they got some
shots I don't I don't endorse it why I
read an article on as a navy Navy ship
uh-huh that all these you know
servicemen yeah had the flu shot and 80
percent of people on a bulk at the flu
uh-huh okay yeah so that tells you how
efficacious it is and there are studies
that showed it might work about 15 to 9
to sit at a time uh-huh so how about
there's a shot I don't know if you've
heard of the Hajj it's one of the fifth
pillars of Islam where you go to Mecca
first this is where Muslims go to and
there's a shot that's recommended I had
to take it okay
it's the meningitis shot sure I don't
know if you know much about it and I
don't never been okay I take the minutes
yeah it's one of the requirements to go
to Hajj so I go I go take the shot I
never you can't get be exempted from
because I believe there were laws in the
state yeah but let me tell you what
happened now I don't you know how you
remember certain significant things in
your life sure it's supposed to prevent
you from mangina as you can see I never
been so sick in my life I got so I felt
I was gonna die I'm not exaggerate I
felt I was gonna die like hey I'll say
I'll tell you what he knows what ory
yeah they're all the same
you know I the last time I took uh got
one of those shots and I was a senior in
medical school and I was working with a
physician and he convinced me somehow I
just didn't know any better
yeah he gave me the flu shot the last
time I got seriously ill and what I'm
saying for me I mean if I get sick I'm
done with it in a day yeah maybe two
okay
I'm feeling fine I'm still working I
don't take any time on a work when it's
Vic I still feel okay but I was I was
you know coughing up blood I had a look
at a full-blown pneumonia from the from
that yeah and it lasted for about a week
that was very unusual for me man so I
don't know what was going on in my head
at the time but but I did you know I did
that but I just don't do it yeah so so
there are you mentioned some exceptions
as you can tremendous I've seen a lot of
vaccine related side effects no no you
said exempt so you can caucus today yeah
oh yeah I have a lot of patients who
have to sign religious exemptions okay
there's they have to explain why a lot
of the patients because a lot of these
vaccines that use human DNA yeah and so
they write that you know that they're
against all of that stuff so I think one
last thing I want to finish off with no
matter what you do you decide to put
these toxins in your body whatever the
case I think this makes sense to me that
in for this is a thing that many doctors
have gone away from what is a call-in
it's called informed consent that you're
informing the patient of all of the
potential harms I can come now turn the
sugar course all there's no problems but
if you look at the insert you see all of
the side effects informed consent how
important is that but finish with that
also patients need to know what they're
getting yeah I mean when you have a
surgery you have to sign all these forms
all the potential you know dangers what
can happen it's the same thing with
drugs but physicians don't tell their
patients sometimes the pharmacists will
tell the patient there are actually a
lot more informative going back to the
vaccines I have some colleagues on
California because you know when this
whole thing happened with the measles
they mandated vaccines in California and
there's a there's a network called
physicians for informed consent and they
they started this whole huge coalition
with you know scientific data to fight
this law and they're actually changing
it those of that yeah it whatever you do
is that right get informed get educated
Nina get informed you need to know what
you're taking yeah you need to know the
potential side effects if I prescribe a
medicine I look it up and I show the
patient I said did this is the one that
I think's the least and what I'm saying
if I prescribe something most of stuff
that I'm going to prescribe it probably
blood pressure medicine because some
people just they're not control and
that's rare when I'm saying when I
prescribe it it could be four or five
times a year
forget in a biotics I'm not doing any of
that yeah it's not necessary so but yes
be informed and choose your physicians
well thank you so much for being with us
again also if you want to come visit you
say hello read your book you have
anything any way people are holding I
have a book I don't even have a website
but you talk to my wife doctor Garcia
there's a little bit about me on the
website just go over my name you'll find
you'll find some info thank you god
bless you thank you so much you too and
thank you guys for tuning in to the Dean
show informed consent get educated
before you you put something toxic in
your body really get informed we'll see
you next time until then peace be with
you